- [Narrator] Last year, the
auction house Christie's
sold a JPEG by the artist Beeple
for a record-breaking $69 million.
- Beeple's sale hit the art
market like an earthquake.
- [Narrator] For many,
the sale of this NFT
represents a revolution for the art market
since it was the first piece of art sold
by a major auction house that
does not physically exist.
- There's this real gold rush feel
to sort of being on the ground
floor of something dynamic.
And with that comes a lot of risk.
And I think the art market is still trying
to figure out where this will go
but I don't think it's going anywhere.
(gavel banging)
- Sold to you out there online. Thank you.
- [Narrator] So how are NFTs
transforming the art market?
And if this technology goes mainstream,
who stands to benefit?
- Let's give him a Cyberquad.
- [Narrator] This is Niche Markets,
a series about small, lesser-known markets
that despite their size,
(till clanging)
punch well above their weight.
In 2021, the concept
of a non-fungible token
or NFT entered the zeitgeist.
- NFTs in 2021 were an
incredibly important milestone.
It has a really revolutionary impact
on the art business.
- NFTs for me, it's a new genre of art.
- Digital art has existed for decades.
I think we will always think of a before
and an after in terms of NFTs.
- [Narrator] NFTs are digital tokens
with vouchers of authenticity
that represent digital or
real-life art or collectibles.
- An NFT is essentially a receipt
that you can never throw away.
If you need proof that you own a thing,
an NFT is one way to
lock that down forever.
- [Narrator] Although NFTs have
been around for a few years,
it wasn't until 2021
when they really began
to attract widespread attention.
- So we are in my living room
and we're watching the
closing of the auction.
- [Narrator] The artist
behind this piece of work
is Mike Winkelmann,
better known as Beeple.
69 million.
I think it probably means
digital art is here to stay.
- [Narrator] Christie's
says the sale of "Everydays"
makes Beeple among the top three
most valuable living artists.
A fact made all the more remarkable
since "Everydays" began bidding at $100.
- It was truly a watershed moment.
It introduced NFTs into
the auction world in 2021,
which was really the biggest
headline for our business.
- For him to come in with
essentially a JPEG collage
and outsell Frida Kahlo and Salvador Dali,
I mean, the art market
couldn't wrap its head
around what we were experiencing.
And it was definitely a
marker of a brand new world.
(playful music)
(keys clacking)
- [Narrator] Artist Cam
Rackam spends his days
in his Southern California
studio creating NFTs.
- I've been a artist for 18 years.
I started dappling with
NFTs during the pandemic.
I thought it was gonna be two weeks
and it just went on and on.
I watched my art shows melt away.
- [Narrator] Before the pandemic,
Rackam's income came mostly
from gallery sales and commissions.
But lockdowns put him on unemployment
and forced him to pivot his business.
- NFTs have massively changed my life.
Let's give him a little
Wall Street Bull sign.
I didn't plan for that or expect that.
There we go.
But I went from marginally
successful painter
to full-time NFT maker.
- [Narrator] Rackam is the
artist behind a collection
of NFTs known as Wall Street Bulls,
which is comprised of
10,000 cartoon bull NFTs.
- This one has a pipe,
this one has a laser eye.
This one has a goatee.
Maybe a beard.
- [Narrator] Each of the
Wall Street Bull NFTs
parodies different aspects
of today's social media-fueled
retail trading culture.
- AOC, we gave her her
famous tax the rich dress
and she's got commie
horns and a Bernie tattoo.
- [Narrator] The collection was produced
in partnership with the team
behind the satirical Instagram
account Wall Street Memes,
which takes much of its inspiration
from the popular wallstreetbets subreddit
that was at the center of
last year's GameStop mania.
- We thought with being
bullish on the market,
the bull as a character
made a lot of sense to us.
That's J.P. Morgan and
John D. Rockefeller.
- [Narrator] Although the
sales that have grabbed many
of the headlines have to do
with specific works of art,
like Beeple's "Everydays" or "HUMAN ONE,"
some of the most popular
NFTs bought and sold today
are part of collections.
- The really cool thing
about how NFTs have really exploded
is that it's given sort of
all kinds of art a chance
to shake out and find its
own subcategory, right?
So you have the apes and the Dogecoins
and the various animal creatures.
They're almost similar
to being part of a club.
- [Narrator] NFT collections tend
to follow a release strategy
similar to sneaker drops.
They come in limited quantities,
depend on sky-high demand
and stir speculative crazes
in the secondary market.
- The secondary market is like...
It's probably the most beautiful part
of the NFT selling spectrum.
- [Narrator] Thanks to a
few lines of code embedded
within an NFT,
artists are guaranteed a cut
of any and all future sales
of their work in perpetuity.
- Now as an artist, you
can collect a royalty.
As a creator, a developer,
you do get kind of what
you deserve finally.
(playful music)
- [Narrator] Rackam told The Journal
that the Wall Street
Bulls collection sold out
in 32 minutes,
netting the team behind
it an initial profit
of $2.6 million of which
his take home was $726,000.
Since the project went
live on October 27th,
Rackam said he's made an
additional $62,000 in royalties.
- We've been in this
kind of auction house,
corporate contemporary
world for a very long time.
NFTs are so much more democratic.
There we go.
- We come to a place where
artists have more say
over where their works go
and they have more, you
know, they're getting a cut
of resales and they're
knowing where everything is.
I mean, certainly that
does shift the balance
of power a little bit
in the favor of the little guy
and of the artist as opposed
to the power brokers.
- [Narrator] These new buyers
are far younger than those
who typically participate
in high-priced auctions.
- 75% of the people who participated
in our NFT sales this year
were entirely new to Christie's.
Our average NFT buyer's 42 years old.
That's more than 10 years younger
than the buyers across categories.
- Ahead of you in Hong Kong.
16 is here, thank you.
- [Narrator] To cater
to this new clientele,
the 255-year-old auction house
changed its payment policies.
- We had to expedite our readiness
to accept cryptocurrency
because it was absolutely demanded by some
of the avid NFT buyers.
And now we're delighted
that we're actually
accepting cryptocurrency
not only for NFT works
but for works across other categories.
- The much anticipated sequel
to Beeple's first offering
here at Christie's.
- [Narrator] In 2021, Christie's
sold around $150 million
in NFTs for 8% of its
contemporary art sales.
- We think NFTs are here to stay.
We've had great conversations
with so many artists,
musical artists, visual artists,
so I think the sky's the limit.
- Here in the moment, $24 million.
25 online.